[Music]
look it doesn't matter which shooter you
play
there is one thing you're just gonna
have to know how to do
aim
whether you're looking to become the
next device trying to take sentinels
down a notch or ushering in an era of
utility based trick shotting
there's just no getting around the fact
that no matter how much of a flashing
smoking shot calling wall opening
support player you fancy yourself
at some point you're gonna have to click
ahead and at some point you're gonna
have to hit that head simple and zeus
combined to take down kerrigan they've
gotta recover a neat goal as a
tremendous excuse me job of doing so
drop down right now
has he done that
oh that's gonna rattle nico oh wow
the question that haunts all of us every
single day is how do we most effectively
improve our aim it could be that you've
spent 10 000 hours in aimbots have
become obsessed with smoking all 30 of
these pricks in the range or just wish
that you'd stop getting pop flash by
[ __ ] stewie2k in siege's so-called
training grounds or maybe you've bought
into the hype and tried out one of these
increasingly popular allegedly
groundbreaking aim trainers these days
it feels as if you can't be a true
clouted aimer if you're not flexing your
grid shot score on social media or
putting it to the test in actual
tournaments
oh
my god
what we want to know is what you want to
know is the sudden explosivity of aim
trainers all a result of marketing or is
there something actually scientific at
play in other words are aim trainers
better than your traditional age-old
warm-up and if so
how much better
[Applause]
okay so before we dive into this video
please take a second and like it
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications
and even do a little aim game if you
want and just
click between the three of them fast
okay so silly question i know but first
things first
what is a name trainer an aim trainer is
essentially any sort of custom practice
oriented playstage created in or outside
of the game engine in which you
regularly compete
from flash games to workshop maps to
first party warm-up tools an aim trainer
is anything that was designed to well
train aim what's interesting is that for
a very long time such tools
were actually not that easy to come by
you see once upon a time the only way
for us boomers to refine the intricacies
of our fragging
outside of in an actual match that is or
in a bot match was to load into a custom
map find yourself a nice clean looking
wall pick two points to flick between
and well and shoot at him a bunch of
course at some point people got bored of
staring at textures all day and started
building [ __ ] to better improve their
face clicking abilities from recoil maps
to 1v1 arenas to the ever
ever-infuriating death match server it
was modders who made aim training into
what it is today the issue of course is
that there wasn't sort of one central
unifying aim instructor but rather a
bunch of disparate ones depending on
what you played and what you wanted to
work on in cs go for instance there have
always been tons of options from aimbots
to recoil master to an inexhaustible sea
of reflex and or reaction simulators
unfortunately the same couldn't be said
for a title like siege where to this day
training and warm-up begins and ends
with t hunt
hello
oh that's very bad then of course you
had class slash arena shooters like
quake team fortress 2 and overwatch
where at least in terms of the latter
two custom content continues to reign
supreme of course there is one other aim
development tool that players of all
games indulge in from time to time but
it's cursed and annoying and i can't
believe they're gonna make me talk about
it on my own goddamn show then i guess
it's a pretty good thing that they keep
me around the other aim development tool
that he's talking about that really
isn't a name trainer at all
is osu osu is a rhythm game that popped
up in 2007. there are a few different
modes but for this video we're just
going to stick to osu standard where you
click circles drag sliders and spin
circles to the beat of a song just
looking at it the similarities to an aim
trainer are pretty obvious all the beat
maps are community made and most of them
are at least let's say anime adjacent
but for a kid who grew up on console
shooters who had a background in music
osu was a pivotal tool for me as i
transitioned into using my mouse for pc
shooters and it's proven to be popular
among plenty of pros and streamers as
well one notable example is tens if
you're a valorant playing zoomer odds
are pretty good his stream was your
introduction to osu anyways osu has
beatmap high score lists which are a
similar sort of bragging right as an
aimlab score you can tweet out for a few
dozen likes but osu is very much a
competitive game in its own right with a
world cup every year since 2011 and
legendary players like cookie z or white
cat there are plenty of options out
there if you're looking to get a little
more accurate with your mouse or just
work on your hand-eye coordination just
don't let crusty old boomers like
dimitri tell you osu isn't a great route
just because they're too cool for
anything even tangentially related to
anime and dimitri just remember that the
other editors and i can cut you out of
your own goddamn show any time that we
want
so watch it suffice it to say with
esports on the rise and fortnight
inspiring 13 year olds to get into
shooters like never before
people figured that there had to be a
better cleaner way to practice one's aim
one that didn't involve
in weird anime music thus in 2018 we
entered the era of the so-called actual
all-encompassing aim trainer with the
release of aimlab and kovac 2.0 now
these were full-featured highly
customizable clients that sought to
simulate or recreate the conditions of
nearly every shooter on the market
aimlab is a free aim training solution
on steam combining science with practice
scenarios to help you improve your
aiming ability taking your game to the
next level aimlab is the most popular
way to nuttify one's aim of course since
it well it has the biggest marketing
budget which hey isn't a bad thing
but it didn't come first from what i can
gather former quake competitor kovac
began building his aim trainer back in
2016 after years of uploading
arena-centric fps tutorials on his
youtube channel this dude was a true
pioneer one who paved the way for aim
educators everywhere what aimlab is or
at the very least claims to be is the
most scientifically grounded of said
trainers and what we want to know is
whether that's true because suffice it
to say it didn't take long for aim lab
scores to start becoming a benchmark of
sorts a go-to flex for any and all
respected aimers to demonstrate just how
check his game and pc that is not
normally they really were
i hit 130 that's my highest it also
didn't take long for the rest of us to
start imitating said maestros
to
varying degrees of success
you see what separated something like
aim lab from the fray is that it offered
personalized tailor-made feedback it
assessed and by extension addressed the
strengths and weaknesses surrounding
your aim in particular if you've played
the task in aimlab you've probably seen
the insights page screaming at you that
you've got a left or a right side
weakness it's one of the most common
messages that tons of aimless players
get i asked sue about this who you
probably know as the analyst of g2's
world championship winning rainbow six
siege roster since he now works as aim
labs rainbow six siege product manager
and he explained to me what aimlab's
sort of holistic goal is so aimleb was
founded by wayne mckay who is a
neuroscientist from new york and
he was a gamer all all the time like
from heart and
he took a more scientific like a more
scientific approach to aim training or
like training for games in general and
that's why aim lab is broken up into six
categories that is flicking tracking
speed that's like your main
aim components then you have precision
perception and cognition so we also dive
into
learning on how to recognize when
something moves on your screen like when
you hold an angle like a small pixel
moves
you can train this enamel
now in theory all of this is great game
changing even
but does it really help in practice
wouldn't it be better to just train in
the game engine in which you'll be
competing
for me i'm a person that um
surely i'm growing up in the old way and
for me we never had those tools so it's
a little bit different for me than maybe
someone that's here that's used to
having these tools that you can train on
every day
um
so for me i think that still the best
practice to this day and i think it's
gonna take a long time till it be like
oh this is the way to go with it's
probably that much um it's because you
get the simple reality that happens in a
game
and let me tell you you do not have to
go all the way back to 1.6 to find them
blame f for instance is famous for
having grinded out like 10 000 headshots
per day in aimbots before going pro is
it true that you practice 10 000
headshots for three hours every day i
don't do it anymore but i definitely did
it for like a period of eight months
without the out questioning i streamed
it most of the time as well then you've
got someone like bolo who t hunted his
way to siege glory becoming arguably the
most mechanically talented player his
game has ever seen using what is
unquestionably the worst warm-up tool in
fps in fact that was one of the things
that aimlabs sought to rectify and boy
did they
as someone that has a rainbow six
background it's kinda like a project
that comes from heart when you're like
siege is a nice game it's really fun to
play but it's really hard to practice
rainbow six
so building stuff a name that like it's
so easy to build stuff name like i don't
have to be a developer to build a task
like i just need
20 minutes to learn creator studio and i
can build my own stuff like
yesterday like yesterday i died to a
certain angle i can build this angle in
aimlept within 15-20 minutes and
practice on killing this guy next time
so if you're a siege player aimlab could
honestly be a godsend there's no death
match t-hunt sucks and who knows when
ubisoft is going to release that
practice range we've been waiting 84
years to behold aimlab knows this and
they're doing a killer job of
capitalizing on it the question
naturally is how useful are aim trainers
in other fps titles where players have
infinitely more tools at their disposal
like is your time best spent spider
shotting all day or would you be better
off death matching doing retakes or god
forbid learning smokes i wanted to know
so i reached out to dr madison
klarkowski a professor at the university
of saskatchewan
who not only specializes in computer
human interaction but has been
conducting research into the efficacy of
what she termed atomizing skill sets in
esports we are actually doing like
myself and my colleagues were actually
looking into a similar topic and what we
were looking into was um essentially
breaking down skills into their
components so the times we've been using
is atomizing like looking at the atoms
of skills
now in her opinion aim trainers are
actually fantastic tools for improving
the mechanics of amateurs and experts
alike
why
well because in addition to atomizing
the various aspects of one's aim they
offer a very sophisticated form of
something very
very valuable
feedback
aim trainers do kind of break this down
to a more granular level they allow for
a great amount of very detailed feedback
and knowledge of results is a type of
feedback pertaining to how successful
you are and showing um how successful
you are or showing a person you know how
successful they successfully they're
able to achieve i know for example
uh accuracy how accurate they were this
research shows that having this kind of
feedback does improve
learning and performance
now from what professor klarkowski told
me this knowledge of results is super
important because it not only allows us
to compartmentalize our skills
but spot treat them
i mean trainers do give you this
wonderful knowledge of results and that
you can look at a very very granular
level at for example your weaknesses
like maybe doing certain tasks helps you
realize you know you're a great you're
great at tapping you're great at
tracking but maybe your flicking is less
than stellar um and it allows you to
identify those weaknesses and kind of
spot treat those areas
now this is a deep topic and i will not
have time to delve into even a fraction
of any of it
what i will emphasize is that as with
all forms of practice aim training is
only really beneficial to us if we
engage in it meaningfully reflectively
and as the sports scientists refer to it
deliberately
say in uh in golf was an example we've
been using um you analyze things like
foot placement and your backstroke and
like all these minor components come in
um that make up the composite of the
larger skill in play
suffice it to say aim trainers are great
at honing our play
but they can't teach us how to play
because in a tactical shooter like cs go
valorant or siege
knowing which fights to take will almost
always outweigh how cracked you are when
you take them i think aim trainers are
super helpful aimlabs is really nice for
focusing on isolated aim mechanics
but you still need to focus on the game
of your choice when when you guys think
about like how to aim better you you
think of just like running around and
just like flicking to people that's not
how to aim in this game in in games like
uh counter-strike it's
strategic based like the maps the
layouts and everything are the same you
have these fixed angles that you want to
practice you want to know the the angles
you want to know where you should
position yourself you want to know where
the enemy is going to be positioned all
that goes into factor into your aim
before you even think about like
raw adjusting your aim where you come
out and someone's where they're not
supposed to be and then you flick to
them and according to professor
klarkowski it is here where knowledge of
results comes face to face with its
opposite dichotomized counterpart namely
the intuitive or intellectual
understanding of an esport which she
referred to as knowledge of performance
knowledge of results might be like
you've achieved 87 hedgehog accuracy but
knowledge of performance might be
something like your crosshair placement
is whack or you know there's no point
crouch spamming at silver because no
one's going to be aiming at your head
anyway so you may as well stand still um
otherwise they'll accidentally shoot you
in the head um
that kind of that knowledge of
performance that you get from those
comments that's not something you're
going to get from from aim trainers
right but maybe it will be in the future
but at the moment we're pretty limited
to the metrics from your results the
knowledge of performance is something
that you will get from
a coach or a teammate or a human
spectating your game and helping you so
that's where you actually do need to
play the game to get that knowledge of
performance
now is it true that there are some
aimers who are just so nutty that they
can take pretty much any fight they want
uh
yeah but they are few and far between
not everyone's are twists or attends and
while we should all strive to be that
insane we shouldn't expect to be
oh my god that was dirty of course
that's not to say that we won't all
inevitably find ourselves in a situation
where a thousand hours of aim lab ends
up coming in handy just the other day i
found myself wide swinging tree room a
little too hastily and
well this happened
thanks
cs go hub
i don't know i i don't really use aimlab
point is these type of flicks while
certainly very stylish
aren't really something you want to rely
on like aside from the fact that they're
not sustainable
aim just
isn't as important as intellect look at
xaiwu kid's got world-class aim don't
get me wrong but what really stands out
about him is his 2 billion iq game sets
who needs sick swanky wrist shattering
flicks when you've got wall hacks
installed in your brainstem
so is it safe to say that specialized
scientifically oriented aim trainers
like aim lab are worth investing your
time and energy into
most definitely how much of your time
and energy
as much as you can
just try to make sure that you don't
become better at the trainer than you
are at the game for which you're
training at a certain point when aim the
aim trainer becomes the priority or when
that's all that you're playing or the
ratio is out of whack and you're playing
you know
10 times as much um aim trainers as you
are the game itself
you know i would agree that you kind of
become adapted to that
and that would kind of be
where you improve the most as opposed to
in the game itself so it's all about
taking those skills from aimlab and
applying them so you want to make sure
that you do practice um in the
environment that you want to improve in
as well because there's so many aspects
of the game itself that just can't be
replicated in aim trainers as in all
things moderation is essential ensure
that your training regime is
well-rounded and you'll be fine for all
of you kings and queens out there who've
already taken up aim trainers keep at it
and for those of you like me who haven't
really given them that much of a fair
shake
why not try them out can't hurt to be
more cracked
okay
[Music]
oh my god
just because they're too cool for
anything even tangentially related to
anime
i ran out of breath
[Music]